hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with Hong Kong compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
sc.l2-3.13.15 protect the authenticity
of communication sessions
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you if you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so uh here's a question is
it really you I mean is it you are you
sure it's you this control relates to
making sure that users and their
communication actions are verified
somehow typically this is done by making
sure a user has to log in before being
able to communicate and another method
is by only allowing devices which have
been pre-verified to be acceptable such
as logging a phone into a phone system
via Mac address as is common in most
VoIP systems let's drill into what the
assessor is really looking for on this
one and I think the right answers will
make themselves obvious so what are they
looking for looking to determine if the
authenticity of communication sessions
is protected how do we do that a lot of
different ways
uh so it could be via uh multi-factor
authentication on communication sessions
uh uh and encryption certificates which
are verified to be implemented and
working correctly by it administrators
uh where required of course uh to
protect the authenticity of
communication sessions under the
company's management that's definitely a
very relevant answer other ways are that
you know you may have to only allow
certain people with a password into an
online meeting that's a great way to
verify the authenticity is if you set up
passwords on your Zoom meetings uh you
know or teams another way is again you
know teams verifying who can come via
the email address of course that's one
way and then finally you know again by
only being allowed to use devices that
are physically within a network that are
hooked up to a Voiceover IP system is
one other way although that one's kind
of a little bit of a stretch unless
you've got a password to actually use
the phone but I have seen that feature
so it's worth mentioning now if you are
a defense contractor and you have just
had this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into your lap
like a seagull on a sunny day or you're
struggling Under the Mountain of
policies that you've got to write and
all of the struggle struggles you've got
to go through just in order to figure
out how to be compliant with this stuff
the great news is we can help Okay we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmccompliance secrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better You Guessed
It smash the Subscribe button to get the
latest compliance content as soon as our
compliance centers roll it out and I
gotta tell you every time we hit a new
subscriber we jump for joy around here
hit the gong it's a big win and you know
what everybody's having a party until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign